hey vsauce michael here and the itunes
store contains 28 million
different songs last fm carries
45 million songs and the grace note
database of artists titles and labels
contains 130 million
different songs that's a lot if you were
to listen to all of the songs in the
grace note database one after the other
and a giant playlist
it would take you more than 1200 years
to complete but since there are a
finite number of tones our ears can
distinguish
and because it only takes a few notes in
common for two musical ideas
to sound similar will we ever
run out of new music
will there ever be a day where every
possible brief little melody has been
written and recorded and we are left
with nothing
new to make a good rule of thumb might
be to say that if modern recording
technology can't distinguish the
difference between two songs
well neither could we so let's begin
there with digital downloads mp3s
cds and a calculation made by covered
in bees digital music
is made out of bits lots and lots of
bits
but each individual bit exists in one of
two states
a zero or a one now what this means
is that for any given say five minute
long audio file
the number of possibilities
mathematically speaking is enormous
but mind-blowingly finite
a compact disc which samples music at
44.1 kilohertz
is going to need about 211 million bits
to store one
5-minute song and because a bit can
exist in two states either a 0 or a 1
the number of possible different ways to
arrange those 211 million
bits is 2 to the 211 millionth
power that value represents every single
possible
different five-minute long audio file
but how big is that number well let's
put this in perspective
a single drop of water contains 6
sextillion atoms 6
sextillion is 22 digits
long it's a long number but the total
number of atoms that make up the entire
earth
is a number that is about 50 digits long
and estimations of the total number of
hydrogen atoms
in our universe is a number that is
80 digits long
but 2 to the 211 millionth power the
number of possible
different five-minute audio files is a
number that is
63 million
digits long it is a number
larger than we can even pretend
to understand it contains every possible
cd-quality 5-minute audio file
inside that amount is everything from
beethoven's fifth
to beck's loser it even contains a
five-minute conversation you had with
your parents
when you were three years old in fact
every one of them
it even contains every possible
conversation you didn't have with your
parents when you were three years old
but it is finite not infinite
it's cool to think about but it doesn't
come very close to answering the
question of this video which is
how many possible different songs
can we create and hear the difference
between
so for that we're going to need to
narrow down our hunt
on everything too ferrous lepidoptera
made a calculation
that involved some assumptions that i
think helped narrow the field down
in a really nice way she took a look at
the total number of
possible different melodies you could
create within one
octave containing any or all of the
intervals
we divide octaves into of course
sound frequencies can be divided much
more granularly
than that but giving ourselves more
notes might mean we could make
more technically different melodies but
they wouldn't necessarily sound any
different
to our ears now given a single measure
containing any combination of whole half
quarter eighth 16th or
32nd notes she calculated that there
would be
this many possible unique
measures which is a smaller number than
we had before
but to put it in perspective this
is how many seconds old
the universe is uric de's calculation
is even more specific he stayed within
one octave
but instead of looking at a complete
measure he only considered the number of
unique combinations
of eight notes he also assumed that
typical melodies as we know them today
only contain about three different
types of note length for instance
quarter eighth and sixteenth or whole
half and quarter
to be sure that will most likely not
always be
true musical tastes hundreds thousands
of years from now will most assuredly be
different but given melodies as we know
them
today across eight notes
over 12 intervals there are about 79
billion possible combinations
we're getting relatively small here i
mean under this definition of melody
100 songwriters creating a brand new
eight note melody every second
would exhaust every possible melody
within only 248 years
but it's still a huge number way bigger
than the total number of songs that have
been written that we know about
so you can quite safely say that no
we will never run out of new music
but here's the rub
if that's the case why are there so many
commonalities between
songs even across hundreds of years how
come so many songs kind of
sound the same i mean if we have more
possibilities than we could ever exhaust
why is twinkle twinkle little star the
alphabet song
and baba black sheep all the same melody
my country tis of thee and god save the
queen interestingly enough
are the same song love me tinder is
exactly the same as the old american
civil war song
ara lee
[Music]
and a seemingly uncountable number of
songs merely
sound like other songs the spongebob
squarepants theme
has a very similar cadence to blow the
man down
soundsjustlike.com is a great resource
for exploring this further it'll show
you two songs
and how they sort of sound alike
[Applause]
[Music]
and when it comes to musical chords it's
almost as if there's no variety at all
as was famously shown by the axis of
awesome's
four chords i've linked it in the
description it's worth a watch if you
haven't seen it already
these guys sing more than 40 different
songs using the same
four chords even though
the number of possible different
melodies is gigantic
us humans tend to gravitate towards
certain patterns that we like more than
others
and we are influenced by what came
before us
kirby ferguson has a fantastic series
looking into this called everything is a
remix i've also linked that down in the
description
the commonalities he shows are pretty
crazy
even when it comes to lyrics to writing
even though mathematically there are
more possibilities than we could ever
exhaust
we have gravitated towards a few
in fact there is a form of poetic meter
that is so
common it's called common
meter i've composed a verse using it to
explain what it is
line one contains eight syllables
the next contains just six for
emphasis iambic stress that's it
no other tricks here is a list of
songs that are written in common meter
also known
as valid meter the commonness of
common meter is the reason you can sing
the pokemon theme song
to the tune of gilligan's island or
house of the rising sun
or amazing grace you could also use
almost any of emily dickinson's poetry
sure they're different melodies but
their lyrics are written in the same
meter there's a great video here on
youtube that i've linked below in the
description that uses
captions to let you see just how these
all fit together
oh and don't forget one of the greatest
compositions taking advantage
of common meters commonness stairway
to gilligan's island and you know what
our brains may also be keeping us from
enjoying the entire mathematical space
of available songs for instance research
has
shown that the way a song compresses
using
software can help us predict how
enjoyable
it will be too simple too easy
to compress like say a rising scale and
the song doesn't
challenge us it's boring but too
complicated
say white noise and the file won't
compress very much at all
and likewise we don't seem to enjoy it
there's a magic
zone where a file is compressible by a
computer
and also happens to be enjoyable by us
so interestingly even though
mathematically speaking
there are so many possible unique
melodies that we can safely
say there will always be room for new
music
we don't seem to be wired to care
we enjoy certain patterns and melodies
and calculating how many there could be
is a lot less interesting than how
connected and similar all the ones that
we
enjoy are it's as if we have
more space than we need more space than
we could ever hope to see
all of or visit all of or know all of
but no matter
what new place we go in a general sense
new popular music
will always remind us a bit of home
and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
fantastic you're still here if you want
to hear music from
people like you from vsaucers go check
out
we sauce you can submit music animation
short films
anything that you're making and putting
on youtube to us
and we'll feature it on vsauce it's like
a trailer for what vsaucers
are doing speaking of which jake chudno
who does
all of the music in these videos has a
brand new song out over on his channel
which i highly suggest you go give a
listen
you